he worked at Twitter for a bit I did as
an intern
the world's greatest intern
all right there's been better that's
been better uh tell me about your time
at Twitter how did it come about and
what did you did you learn from the
experience
so I deleted my first Twitter in 2010
I had a hundred thousand followers back
when that actually meant something and
I just saw you know
my co-worker summarized it well he's
like whenever I see someone's twitter
page I either think the same of them or
less of them I never think more of them
yeah right like like you know I don't
want to mention any names but like some
people who like you know maybe you would
like read their books and you would
respect them you see them on Twitter and
you're like
okay dude
yeah but there's some people with same
you know who I respect a lot are people
that just post really good technical
stuff yeah
and I guess
I don't know I think I respect them more
for it because you you realize oh this
wasn't uh there's like so much depth to
this person to their technical
understanding of so many different
topics okay so I try to follow people I
try to consume stuff that's Technical
Machine learning content there's
probably a few of those people
and the problem is inherently what the
algorithm rewards right and people think
about these algorithms people think that
they are terrible awful things and you
know I love that Elon open sourced it
um because I mean what it does is
actually pretty obvious it just predicts
what you are likely to retweet and like
and Linger on
let's put all these other things do with
Tick Tock does so all these
recommendation editors do
and it turns out that the thing that you
are most likely to interact with is
outrage
and that's a quirk of The Human
Condition
I mean and there's different flavors of
outrage it doesn't have to be it could
be mockery
you could be outraged the topic of
outrage can be different it could be an
idea it could be a person it could be
and maybe there's a better word than
outrage it could be drama sure all this
kind of stuff yeah but it doesn't feel
like when you consume it it's a
constructive thing for the individuals
that consume it in the long term yeah so
my time there I absolutely couldn't
believe you know I got
crazy amount of hate uh you know just on
Twitter for working at Twitter it seems
like people associated with this I think
maybe uh you were exposed to some of
this the connection to Elon or is it
working on Twitter Twitter and Elon like
the whole there's just elon's gotten a
bit spicy during that time a bit
political a bit yeah
yeah you know I remember one of my
tweets it was never go full Republican
and Elon liked it
you know
oh boy I uh yeah I mean there's a roller
coaster of that but being political on
Twitter yeah boy yeah and also being
just attacking anybody on Twitter it
comes back at you harder
and if his political and attacks sure
sure absolutely
and then letting
uh
sort of D platform people back on
even adds more fun to the to the to the
beautiful chaos I was hoping and like I
remember when Elon talked about buying
Twitter like six months earlier he was
talking about like a principled uh
commitment to free speech and I'm a big
believer and fan of that I would love to
see an actual principled commitment to
free speech
um of course this isn't quite what
happened
um instead of the oligarchy deciding
what to ban you had a monarchy deciding
what to ban right instead of you know
all the Twitter files Shadow and really
they're the oligarchy just decides what
cloth masks are ineffective against
covid that's a true statement every
doctor in 2019 knew it and now I'm
banned on Twitter for saying it
interesting oligarchy um so now you have
a monarchy and uh you know you you he
bans things he doesn't like
uh so you know it's just it's just
different it's different power and like
you know maybe I uh maybe I align more
with him than with the oligarchy but
it's not explosion but I feel like being
a face-to-peach absolutist on The Social
Network requires you to also have tools
for the individuals
to
control what they consume easier like uh
not sensor you know yeah but just like
control like oh I like to see more cats
and less politics and this isn't even
this isn't even remotely controversial
this is just saying you want to give
paying customers for a product what they
want yeah right and not through the
process of censorship but through the
process of like well it's individualized
right it's individualized transparent
censorship which is honestly what I want
what is an ad blocker it's
individualized transparent censorship
right yeah but censorship is a strong
word
and people are very sensitive to I know
but you know I just use words to
describe what they functionally are and
what is an ad blocker it's just
censorship well when I look at you right
now I'm censoring I'm looking at you I'm
censoring
everything else out when I'm full when
my mind is focused on you that's you can
use the word censorship that way but
usually when people get very sensitive
about the censorship thing I I think
when you have when anyone is allowed to
say anything
you should probably have tools
that maximize the quality of the
experience for individuals so you know
for me like what I really value boy
would be amazing to somehow figure out
how to do that I love this agreement and
debate and people who disagree with each
other disagree with me especially in the
space of ideas but the high quality ones
so not derision right Maslow's hierarchy
of argument I think it's a real word for
it probably yeah there's just a way of
talking that's like snarky and so on
that somehow is gets people on Twitter
and they get excited and so on we have
like ad hominem refuting the Central
Point I've like seeing this as an actual
pyramid something yeah it's yeah and
it's it's like all of it all the wrong
stuff is attractive to people I mean we
can just train a classify her to
absolutely say what level of Maslow's
hierarchy of argument are you at and if
it's ad hominem like okay cool I turned
on the no ad hominem filter
I wonder if there's a social network
that will allow you to have that kind of
filter yeah so uh here's a problem with
that
um it's not going to win in a free
market
what wins in a free market is all
television today is reality television
because it's engaging right if if
engaging is what wins in a free market
right so it becomes hard to keep these
other more nuanced values
well okay so that's the experience of
being on Twitter but then you got a
chance to also
together with other engineers and with
Elon sort of look brainstorm when you
step into a code base it's been around
for a long time you know there's other
social networks you know Facebook this
is old code basis and you step in and
see okay
how do we make with a fresh mind uh
progress on this code base like what
what did you learn about software
engineering about programming from just
experiencing that so my technical
recommendation to Elon and I said this
on the Twitter spaces afterward I said
this many times during my brief
internship
um
was that you need refactors before
features
um this code base was and look I've
worked at Google I've worked at Facebook
uh Facebook has the best code
uh then Google then Twitter
um and you know what you can know this
because look at the machine learning
Frameworks right Facebook released
pytorch Google release tensorflow and
Twitter released
okay so you know it's a proxy but yeah
they're the the Google Club is quite
interesting there's a lot of really good
software Engineers there but the code
base is very large the code base was
good in 20 and 2005. right it looks like
2005. there's so many products so many
teams right it's very difficult to
um I feel like Twitter does less like
obviously much less than Google
in terms of like the set of features
right
so like it's I can imagine the number of
software Engineers that could recreate
Twitter is much smaller than to recreate
Google yeah I still believe in the
amount of hate I got for saying this
that 50 people could build and maintain
Twitter
uh pretty what's the nature of the hate
comfortably
that you don't know what you're talking
about you know what it is and it's the
same this is my summary of like the hate
I get on Hacker News it's like
when I say I'm going to do something
they
have to believe that it's impossible
yeah because if doing things was
possible they'd have to do some soul
searching and ask the question why
didn't they do anything so when you say
hey and I do say that's where the hate
comes from when you say well there's a
core truth to that yes when you say I'm
going to solve self-driving
people go like what are your credentials
what the hell are you talking about what
is this is extremely difficult problem
of course you're a noob that doesn't
understand the problem deeply
um I mean that that was the same nature
of hate that probably Elon got when you
first talked about it Tom was driving
uh but you know there's pros and cons to
that because like you know there is
experts in this world
no but the mockers aren't experts the
market the the people who are mocking
are not experts with carefully reasoned
arguments about why you need 8 000
people to run a bird app there but the
people are gonna lose their jobs
well that but also there's the software
Engineers that probably could have says
no it's a lot more complicated than you
realize but maybe it doesn't need to be
so complicated you know some people in
the world like to create complexity some
people in the world Thrive under
complexity like lawyers right lawyers
want the world to be more complex
because you need more lawyers you need
more legal hours right
um I think that's another if there's two
great evils in the world it's
centralization and complexity yeah and
uh the one of the sort of hidden
uh side effects of software engineering
is
um like finding pleasure and complexity
I mean I don't remember just taking all
the software engineering courses and
just doing programming and this is just
coming up in this uh uh object-oriented
programming kind of idea you don't like
not often do people tell you like do the
simplest possible thing like like a
professor a teacher is not going to get
in front like this is the simplest way
to do it they'll say like this is direct
there's the right way and the right way
at least for a long time you know
especially I came up with like Java
right like is is there's so much
boilerplate so much like
so many classes so many like designs and
architectures and so on like planning
for features far into the future and
planning poorly and all this kind of
stuff and then there's this like code
base that follows you along and puts
pressure on you and nobody knows what
like Parts different parts do which
slows everything down is the kind of
bureaucracy that's instilled in the code
as a result of that but then you feel
like oh well I follow good software
engineering practices it's an
interesting trade-off because then you
look at like the ghettowness of like
Pearl and the old like how quickly you
could just write a couple lines and just
get stuff done that trade-off is
interesting or bash or whatever these
kind of ghetto things you can do in
Linux one of my favorite things to look
at today is how much do you trust your
tests all right we've put a ton of
effort in comma and I put a ton of
effort in tiny grad into making sure if
you change the code and the tests pass
that you didn't break the code yeah now
this obviously is not always true but
the closer that is to true the more you
trust your tests the more you're like oh
I got a pull request and the tests pass
I feel okay to merge that the faster you
can make progress CEO is programming
with tests of Mind developing tests yeah
with that in mind that if it passes it
should be good and Twitter not that
so it was impossible to make progress in
the code base what other stuff can you
say about the code base that made it
difficult uh like what are some
interesting sort of quirks broadly
speaking from that compared to just your
experience with comma and everywhere
else the real thing that I spoke to a
bunch of uh
you know like like individual
contributors to Twitter and I just
started stats I'm like okay so like
what's wrong with this place why does
this code look like this and they
explained to me what Twitter's promotion
system was
the way that you got promoted to Twitter
was you wrote a library that a lot of
people used
right
so some guy wrote an nginx replacement
for Twitter why does Twitter need an
nginx replacement what was wrong with
nginx
well you see you're not going to get
promoted if you use nginx but if you
write a replacement and lots of people
start using it as the Twitter front end
for their product then you're going to
get promoted right so interesting
because like from the individual
perspective how do you incentivize
how do you create the kind of incentives
that will reach or lead to a great code
base what's okay what's the answer to
that
so what I do at comma and at uh
and then you know at tiny Corp is you
have to explain it to me you have to
explain to me what this code does all
right and if I can sit there and come up
with a simpler way to do it you have to
rewrite it
you have to agree with me about the
simpler way um you know obviously we can
have a conversation about this it's not
a it's not dictatorial but if you're
like wow like that actually is way
simpler
like like the Simplicity is important
right but that requires people that
Overlook the code
at the highest levels to be like okay it
requires technical leadership you trust
yeah technical leadership
so managers or whatever should have to
have technical Savvy deep technical
Savvy managers should be better
programmers than the people who they
manage yeah
and that's not always obvious the
trivial to create especially large
companies managers get soft and like you
know and this is just I've instilled
this culture at comma and Kama has
better programmers than me who work
there but you know again I'm like the
you know the old guy from Goodwill
Hunting it's like look man
you know
I might not be as good as you but I can
see the difference between me and you
right and yeah this is what you need
this is what you need at the top or you
don't necessarily need the manager to be
the absolute best I shouldn't say that
but like they need to be able to
recognize skill yeah and have good
intuition intuition that's Laden with
wisdom from all the battles of trying to
reduce complexity in code bases um you
know I took I took a political Approach
at comma too that I think is pretty
interesting I think Elon takes the same
political approach uh you know Google
had no politics and what ended up
happening is the absolute worst kind of
politics took over
um comma has an extreme amount of
politics and they're all mine and no
dissidence is tolerated so it's a
dictatorship yep it's an absolute
dictatorship right Elon does the same
thing now the thing about my
dictatorship is here are my values
yeah so it's transparent it's
transparent it's a transparent
dictatorship right and you can choose to
opt in or you know you get free exit
right that's the beauty of companies if
you don't like the dictatorship you quit
so you mentioned rewrite before or
refactor before features
if you were to refactor the Twitter code
base what would that look like and maybe
also comment on how difficult is it to
refactor the main thing I would do is
first of all identify the pieces and
then put tests in between the pieces
right so there's all these different
Twitter as a microservice architecture
um there's only different microservices
and the thing that I was working on
there look like you know George didn't
know any JavaScript he asked how to fix
search blah blah blah blah blah look man
like
the thing is like I just you know I'm
upset that the way that this whole thing
was portrayed because it wasn't like it
wasn't like taken by people like
honestly it wasn't like by it was taken
by people who started out with a bad
faith assumption yeah and yeah I mean
look I can't like and you as the program
were just being transparent out there
actually having like fun and like this
is what programmers should be about I
love that Elon gave me this opportunity
yeah like really it does and like you
know he came on my my the the day I quit
he came on my Twitter spaces afterward
and we had a conversation like I just I
respect that so much yeah and it's also
inspiring to just engineers and
programmers and just it's cool it should
be fun the people that are hating on it
is like oh man
it was fun it was fun it was stressful
but I felt like you know it was that
like a cool like point in history and
like I hope I was useful I probably kind
of wasn't but like maybe you also were
one of the people that kind of made a
strong case to refactor yeah
and that that's a really
interesting thing to raise like maybe
that is the right you know
the timing of that is really interesting
if you look at just the development of
autopilot you know going
um from mobileye to just like more if
you look at the history of semitan was
driving in Tesla is is more and more
like you could say refactoring or or
starting from scratch redeveloping from
scratch it's refactoring all the way
down and like and the question is like
can you do that sooner
uh can you maintain product
profitability and like what's the what's
the right time to do it how do you do it
you know on any one day it's like you
don't want to pull off the Band-Aids
like it's a
like everything works it's just like
little fix here and there but maybe
starting from scratch this is the main
philosophy of tiny grad you have never
refactored enough your code can get
smaller your code can get simpler your
ideas can be more elegant but would you
consider you know say you are like
running Twitter development teams
engineering teams
would you go as far as like different
programming language just go that far I
mean the first thing that I would do is
build tests the first thing I would do
is get a CI to where people can trust to
make changes
so that if you keep touching any code I
would actually say no one touches any
code the first thing we do is we test
this code base and this is Classic this
is how you approach a legacy code base
this is like what any how to approach a
legacy code base book will tell you
so and then you hope that there's
modules that can live on for a while
and then you add new ones maybe in a
different language or before new ones we
replace old ones yeah yeah meaning like
replace old ones with something simpler
we look at this like this thing that's a
hundred thousand lines and we're like
well okay maybe this did even make sense
in 2010 but now we can replace this with
an open source thing right yeah and you
know we look at this here here's another
50 000 lines well actually you know we
can replace this with 300 lines ago and
you know what I trust that the go
actually replaces this thing because all
the tests still pass so Step One is
testing yeah and then step two is like
the programming languages in
afterthought right you know let a whole
lot of people compete be like Okay who
wants to rewrite a module whatever
language you want to write it in just
the tests have to pass and if you figure
out how to make the test pass but break
the site that's we got to go back to
Step One Step One is get tests that you
trust in order to make changes in the
code base I wonder how hard it is too
because I'm with you on on testing on
everything I have from tests to like
asserts to Every Which code is just
covered in this because uh it should be
very easy to make rapid changes
and no that's not going to break
everything and that's the way to do it
but I wonder how difficult is it to
um integrate tests into a code base that
doesn't have many of them so I'll I'll
tell you what my plan was at Twitter
it's actually similar to something we
use at comma so a comma we have this
thing called process replay and we have
a bunch of routes that will be run
through so comma is a microservice
architecture too with microservices in
the driving like we have one for the
cameras one for the sensor one for the
planner uh one for the model
and we have an API which the
microservices has talked to each other
with we use this custom thing called
serial which uses zmq Twitter uses um
Thrift
and then it uses this thing called
finagle which is a Scala uh
RPC backend but this doesn't even really
matter the thrift and finagle layer was
a great place I thought to write tests
right to start building something that
looks like process replay so Twitter had
some stuff that looked kind of like this
but it wasn't offline it was only online
so you could ship like a modified
version of it and then you could
redirect some of the traffic to your
modified version and diff those two but
it was all online but there was no like
Ci in the traditional sense I mean there
was some but like it was not full
coverage so you can't run all of Twitter
offline to test something then this was
another problem you can't run all of
Twitter
right period Twitter one person camera
Twitter runs in three data centers and
that's it yeah there's no other place
you can run Twitter which is like
George you don't understand this is
modern software development no this is
like why can't it run on my
laptop
yeah okay well I'm not saying you're
gonna download the whole database to
your laptop but I'm saying all the
middleware and the front end should run
on my laptop right that sounds really
compelling yeah
yeah but can that be achieved by a code
base that grows over the years I mean
the three data centers didn't have to be
right because they're totally different
like designs the problem is more like
like why did the code base have to grow
what new functionality has been added to
compensate for the the lines of code
that are there
one of the ways to explain is that the
incentive for software developers to
move up in the companies to add code
to add especially you know what the
incentive for politicians to move up on
the political structures to add laws
yeah same problem yeah
yeah if uh the flip side is to simplify
simplify simplify I mean you know what
this is something that I do differently
from from from Elon with comma about
self-driving cars
but you know I hear the new version is
going to come out and the new version is
not going to be better but at first and
it's going to require a ton of refactors
I say okay take as long as you need
like you convince me this architecture
is better okay we have to move to it
even if it's not going to make the
product better tomorrow the top priority
is making is getting the architecture
right so what do you think about sort of
a thing where the product is online
so how I guess would you do a refactor
if you ran engineering on Twitter would
you just do a refactor how long would it
take what would that mean for the
running of the of the actual service you
know and
I'm not the right person to run Twitter
I'm just not and that's the problem like
like I don't really know I don't really
know if that's you know a common thing
that I thought a lot while I was there
was whenever I thought something that
was different to what Elon thought
I'd have to run something in the back of
my head reminding myself
that Elon is the richest man in the
world
and in general his ideas are better than
mine now there's a few things I think I
do understand and know more about
but like in general
I'm not qualified to run Twitter no it's
gonna say qualified but like I don't
think I'd be that good at it I don't
think I'd be good at it I don't think
I'd really be good at running an
engineering organization at scale
I think I could lead a very good
refactor of Twitter and it would take
like six months to a year and the
results to show at the end of it would
be feature development in general it
takes 10x less time 10x less man hours
that's what I think I could actually do
um do I think that it's the right
decision for the business above my pay
grade
yeah but a lot of these kinds of
decisions are above everybody's pay
grade I don't want to be a manager I
don't want to do that I just like like
if you really forced me to yeah it would
make me maybe
make me upset
if I had to make those decisions
yeah but a refactor is so compelling if
this is to become something much bigger
than what Twitter was
is it feels like a refactor has to be
coming at some point George or Junior
software engineer every Junior software
engineer wants to come in and refactor
with all code
okay like that's like your opinion man
yeah it doesn't you know sometimes
they're right
well like whether they're right or not
it's definitely not for that reason
right it's definitely not a question of
engineering prowess it is a question of
maybe what the priorities are for the
company and I did get more intelligent
like feedback from people I think in
good faith like saying that
um from actually for Milo and like you
know from from Milan sort of like like
people were like well you know I stopped
the world refactor might be great for
engineering but you know we have
business to run
and hey above my pay grade uh what do
you think about Elon as an engineering
leader having to experience them in the
most chaotic of spaces I would say
my respect for Amazon changed
um and I did have to think a lot more
deeply about some of the decisions he's
forced to make
about the tensions within those the
trade-offs within those decisions
about like a whole like
like Matrix coming at him I think that's
Andrew Tate's word for it sorry to
borrow it also the bigger than
engineering it's just everything yeah
like like the war on the woke
yeah like it just it just
man and like
he doesn't have to do this you know he
doesn't have to he could go like parag
and go chill at the four seasons of Maui
you know but see one person I respect
and one person I don't
so his heart is in the right place
fighting in this case for this ideal of
the freedom of expression
I wouldn't Define the ideal so simply I
think you can Define the ideal no more
than just saying elon's idea of a good
world
freedom of expression is
but to you it's still the downsides of
that is the monarchy
yeah I mean monarchy has problems right
but I mean would I trade right now the
Monarch or the current oligarchy which
runs America for the monarchy yeah I
would sure
for the Elon monarchy yeah you know why
because power would cost one cent a
kilowatt hour
tenth of a cent a kilowatt hour
what do you mean right now I pay about
20 cents a kilowatt hour for electricity
in San Diego that's like the same price
you paid in 1980.
what the hell see you would see a lot of
innovation with Elon maybe it'd have
maybe have some hyperloops
yeah right and I'm willing to make that
trade-off right I'm willing to pay and
this is why you know people think that
like dictators take power through some
like
through some untoward mechanism
sometimes they do but usually it's
because the people want them and
the downsides of a dictatorship I feel
like we've gotten to a point now with
the oligarchy where
yeah I would prefer the dictator